[Music]
just when you thought you've seen it all
on breath of the wild well think again
by combining specific rare materials at
a cooking station you'll be able to
create an item that allows you to enter
and operate a guardian now you too can
hop in one of these fierce stoned BOTS
and give the Monsters of Hyrule a taste
of their own medicine warning there are
potential spoilers ahead so if you want
to remind yourself to come back consider
tagging that like button but enough of
that sit back and buckle up its Guardian
go time the first step of the puzzle
involves gathering four rare items
that's going to be one Fang shard from
each of the three dragons and one giant
ancient core you don't have these items
don't worry they're not too difficult to
find but before you hit that trail stock
up on wood and fire dragons tend to
spawn in the morning meaning you're
going to want to start campfires to pass
time for the dragons fair osh head to
the fair and tower and make your way up
to the reoli spring start a fire under a
tree and wait till morning look towards
the spring and this beast should launch
out of the water and down the waterfall
start your approach early to get the
lead on that Fang shot how are you and
be prepared to get hit by choppers
next up nedra jet over to Lynn a Roubaix
here and again start a fire for the
morning this cool dragon coasts in from
the West
time your shot right and pull out that
k9 that's a master level dentistry right
there the last dragon Dan Rahl likes to
start just east of the Tabasco tundra
and Peru south down into the canyon head
over to Hebron tower jump down onto the
canyon edge start a fire wait till
morning baby you got a dragon coming
sharp too through this fire breather and
your gold four giant ancient course you
can find these in shrines or random
drops from Guardian walkers Oh we'll be
back for you bud because right now we're
cooking and over to a cooking station
toss all four items into the pot add a
little dash of love and bam you should
have yourself an ancient Guardian key so
now it's time you find yourself an
operational guardian it's important you
get sneaky because if the Guardian
catches wind of you he'll be in on the
high jinks
so slap on that chica armor and mask
yourself and tallgrass inch your way
towards him
closer take your time wait for the
prompt yeah baby they're pretty easy to
operate hold why to charge that laser
and let them rip hey guys remember me
[Music]
and there you have it your guide to
guardian guiding thanks for watching and
if you have any questions or pointers
about this tip please add them to the
conversation below and hey consider
sharing this tip with friends because
sharing is caring you're welcome